this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armies museum in the uk
which houses a collection of thousands
of iconic weapons from throughout
history
on today's episode he's going to be
checking out the varied arsenal of the
2010 classic fallout new vegas
well i put a smile on the face doesn't
it the fat man nuke launcher
based on some real technology the davey
crockett
tactical nuclear launcher if there are
any other games guns and mechanics that
you guys want to see jonathan break down
let us know in the comments section
below
make sure to subscribe for more videos
like this one and if you'd like to help
out the royal armies museum and continue
to support jonathan's work
check out the links in the description
of this video right
over to jonathan
oh i've not played this in a long time
but this this has been one of my
favorite games but we're not here to
talk about that we're here to talk about
weapons and the the laser rcw
or the uh tommy gun in space
is almost a direct translation of the
actual silhouette of a thompson sub
machine gun to
a fictional laser weapon so much so that
in the first person view
you've actually got the the disassembly
button on the back of the receiver so
there are features that are taken from
the tommy gun that wouldn't even
wouldn't really make sense on the laser
gun
but um looks the part we've still got
the iconic
thompson drum magazine but it stays on
the weapon
and the laser energy
pack is taken off and inserted from the
front of it so
that's interesting as well in the why is
it shaped like a drum
when the drum doesn't even come off and
you're replacing the thing in the middle
so it's a deliberate homage
to the thompson gun something i noticed
because of the
the third person side view that we got
there is the recoil
so this is this is called a laser weapon
and it fires a
pretty much a beam like a pulsed beam of
ostensibly laser light light doesn't
recoil
so unless this is actually a plasma
weapon of some kind and it's just called
a laser gun
it should not recoil into the shoulder
like it does
so i think that's a stylistic choice
because a gun that's as powerful as
relatively powerful as this and is
representing the tommy gun might look
weird if it didn't recoil
well uh to my shame i did not put this
on the table behind me but this
is effectively the anti-materiel rifle
from
fallout new vegas it's by far the
closest
to a real world weapon in the game that
i can think of that i remember
and this is a 50 caliber browning
machine gun
monster and it kind of has to be
hefted to be believed it pretty much
functions as it does
in the game and of course in fallout
this thing is absolutely devastating
and because of the ability to load make
your own ammunition in various different
flavors we saw incendiary in use as well
interestingly when an incendiary round
hits the ground which i hadn't
remembered
um doesn't initiate seemingly but when
it hits a target
human death claw whatever it goes up in
flames appropriately enough and
i'm going to put this down before i hurt
myself
as befits a desert western type
setting albeit in a parallel desolate
future
the single action army cult is still
going strong it's actually quite a good
representation of the single action army
the well the most interesting thing is
the ability to load different ammunition
and to manufacture different ammunition
so we saw
hollow points there which work well
against unarmored targets
not working well against an armored
target and so we see
a switch to normal ammunition either
either
hard cast lead or full metal jacket
would have much the same effect and that
has the penetration to
defeat not modern body armor but um
repurpose sportswear
of the sort that we see in the fallout
universe we've got yet another very
convenient reload animation which i
don't blame them for at all you'd be
there for
quite a while if you had to depict it
realistically so we have the player
incredibly adept at simultaneously
rotating the cylinder and ejecting the
the spam cases which in reality ten
tend to stick in the chamber and need to
be ejected by the ejector rod
and then immediately pressing home the
uh the replacement rounds
it's a system that can be leveraged for
gameplay reasons to make
if you want to make the revolver more
powerful but slower to reload
here it's kind of a balance where it's
moderately powerful
but not as slow to reload as it would be
in real life
come on
we've got a suspiciously mad max looking
character there
wielding that characters or a take on it
iconic
double-barreled sauna shotgun in fact
the fallout version is actually a
craft produced weapon it's not an old
world pre-nuclear
cut down shotgun like the one behind me
there
it's been made from scratch on the
subject of the coin shot
that's i suspect based on real history
in well or at least folklore where you
load a shotgun cartridge with a stack of
quarters or whatever as a sort of home
brew
form of shot as the game calls it coin
shot if metal is scarce
why wouldn't you do that and it wouldn't
be as effective as lead shot but it
would still
hurt
well that puts a smile on the face
doesn't it the uh the fat man nuke
launcher
based on some real technology the um
davey crockett tactical nuclear launcher
it's not quite as portable as this
but it's not too far off crew served so
you need several guys to
carry and operate it terrifying the idea
that we
we were sort of looking at not only
battlefield nukes but
tactical battlefield news so you'd be
within
hundreds of meters of a nuclear
explosion
absolute insanity and luckily we didn't
go down that route but they did in the
fallout universe and so we now have a
shoulder-fired nuclear weapon
used at point-blank range uh technically
point-blank range is
is something else but um in terms of too
close
is the definition of point blank that
yeah that wasn't great i think i saw
some crippled limbs there i think that's
the minimum you'd expect from a nuclear
bomb going off in your face
but it definitely took care of the
critter there
i did forget for a while that the
browning high power was actually in the
game but of course you start the game
with it
and it's pretty much vanilla it's as low
it's been hanging around for
200 years or whatever and it's still
working which is not
entirely implausible like so many of the
game of the guns in this game
weird glitch in the reload animation
well lesser glitch more of an oversight
we've seen in other things where the gun
the slide is forward and when you reload
the slide magically opens to the rear
um sort of shortcutting the the
animation i suppose
but um the high high power is pretty
well represented the cartridge cases
coming out are immense though for some
reason they look like grenade launcher
rounds
not quite sure why that is they wouldn't
they wouldn't fit
in the gun uh we've got a modifications
with
extended magazine and a ipsc style
sight mount now that's something that
definitely wouldn't survive 200 years
knocking around in the wasteland
guns are quite robust optical sights
really aren't
that was the 10 millimeter pistol of
course
this one's been fitted somehow i think
it's modded
with a suppressor which has no hole in
the
end which is bizarre and would result in
it blowing off the end of the gun
now where um reality intersects with
this is
that weapons like the well rod used
rubber wipes
and they do in fact seal off the end of
the suppressor so it almost looks like
there's no hole in the end and then the
first shot
is super quiet because it's having to
penetrate the
the layers of um rubber and then the
subsequent sort of ten or so
shots are very quiet because they're the
gas is sealed behind them as they
squeeze through the rubber
and then after about a dozen shots the
rubber is sufficiently abraded and worn
out that
basically it's back to being a normal
suppressor so it's still working but
it's not
as quiet that's not what we see here
what we see here is a cock-up
to my shame i have still not gone back
and played
fallout one and two i gather that the
the blade runner blaster which is
obviously what we see here
first appeared in fallout 2 i think and
made a reappearance in this game
it's a fair a pretty faithful
representation of this fictional
detective sidearm it's a bit of a
deviation from
the real blade runner blaster in that
well we don't know what
ammunition that chamber is but we don't
even know how it chambers ammunition
because the real prop was a charter arms
bulldog
44 special um with a swing out cylinder
as we see in the fallout version
looks amazing it's one of the most
iconic sci-fi weapons ever but in terms
of how it would work in in the universe
it makes little sense what do the lights
mean what do they do in in fallout we
see
the amber and green light as to to sort
of
denote loaded and unloaded although you
kind of know when it's loaded because
the cylinders in
and so they've kind of recognized that
the blinky lights might have a purpose
the ones on the prop they're just for
show
one of the enjoyable things about the
fallout games is the mixture of
projectile weapons
and effectively ray guns obviously the
the gameplay difference they've gone for
here other than green versus red
is a slow-moving blob i wanted a better
term for the plasma
that when it if if you manage to hit
with it does high damage
whereas the laser is more of a beam and
per shot it's lower damage but if you
get more on target
you do the same damage it's that classic
rpg trade-off but i really like the
design
with the exception of the bizarre energy
system firstly that this power pack at
the bottom is so tiny
doesn't really make much intuitive sense
and secondly that you for some reason
it's installed on a really flimsy
looking bracket
which you then have to you have to
rotate it into contact
why can't you just plug it in but i
quite like how
kind of heath robinson the designs of
these are it's almost like they've got
plasma and laser technology
but they haven't got too far into the
technology of it
before the nukes hit
now it's always a bit sad when we come
to a weapon that we don't have in the
royal armouries collection
and the china lake grenade launcher is
sadly one of those it's not a bad
depiction but the limitations of the
graphics
they based it pretty closely on the real
thing it's got one
extra round uh the china lake only fits
three rounds in
you think of the length of a even the
standard short 40 millimeter grenades
you're struggling to fit more than three
in a weapon that compact
uh we also see plasma rounds being used
and i always find that intriguing
in in my fiction when you've got a sort
of legacy firearm that
is power is multiplied by changing the
ammunition
and we've already seen that you know
we've got modern ammunition loads for
the same cartridge type
for guns 50 100 years old that make them
noticeably more effective and there's no
reason why in the future
that not this but a weapon that we use
today that's less effective in the
future
can keep pace simply by upgrading the
ammunition
i always found the fallout minigun more
appealing as an idea than an actual
weapon i didn't get on with it
particularly well
don't really understand why it's five
millimeter when 5.56 is in the game
the bores of the barrels are very
clearly bigger than five millimeters
the design is not that close to the real
minigun sitting behind me there
it has a cluster of rotating barrels
that's about it really um curiously
although although the character wears a
backpack when he
carries this thing that's not where the
ammunition is but in the game
the ammunition magazine drum thing
whatever the hell it is it's like a
filing cabinet drawer that goes into the
side of the gun
that's what feeds the cartridges so
the backpack is presumably an enormous
battery um it always
always used to work me as well that the
um cartridge cases which get a far too
big for a five millimeter caliber
come kind of tumbling out of the side of
the gun like
20 at a time rapid fire machine guns
like this
tend to have like a cascade of spent
brass but not like a
storm of it coming out the side that
always looked a bit weird
[Music]
this revolver the the ranger sequoia
massive six shooter is fairly
similar to the magnum research bfr we
haven't got one but
i'm not too upset because we do have a
couple of these this is the
century manufacturing model 100
and it is tremendously huge it's also
chambered in 4570
which the bfr in the real world is not
it is a
clone of the single action army like bfr
is and it has a gigantic brass frame
it's actually bigger than the in-game
model unfortunately a quirk of the
in-game model is that it fires with the
hammer down
as though it's a double-action revolver
so when you pull the trigger the hammer
comes back and is released in one go so
yes
ludicrous massively powerful impractical
revolvers do
get made
i've never been entirely clear on how
the gauss gun gauss rifle
in fallout's supposed to work i'm
guessing that the
reloadable cartridge thing is the
projectile
and that somehow the thing is powered or
possibly
that the developers did not know what a
gauss gun is there is a real world
what was the rail gun which uses
parallel rails to accelerate
a projectile so it's a projectile weapon
but it's using tremendous amounts of
energy to accelerate it so it's almost
a hybrid between a projectile and a
directed energy weapon gauss guns as i
understand it are similar principle but
with a
series of coils that accelerate the
projectile that isn't really what we see
and i have a feeling this is just a cool
sci-fi name attached to
a single shot blue energy weapon because
the the
blue energy release that we see on
impact doesn't also doesn't really
reflect how gauss or railguns
actually work the only flash you see
from those
is an explosion effective flame from the
tremendous heat created
by the impact so nice idea but um it's a
perhaps a bit of a fudge
maybe i think that's probably meant to
be a single shot energy weapon
essentially
of all of the machine guns to survive
into the
end of the world i'm not sure that the
fn minimi will be one of them the thing
that really stands out
are the terrible sights weird inverse
iron sights where
the front sight post becomes an aperture
and the rear sight
is a post uh not how sights work
there's also a weird quirk of this in
that the in-game
enemy light machine gun correctly can
chamber and fire both 5.56
and 223 caliber ammunition the
game doesn't take that approach the game
takes the view that 5.56 is military so
it must be more powerful therefore the
2t3 the civilian version
must be less powerful just being 556 or
2t3 doesn't make any difference the
original loads of both
are equally damaging and being again
because it
does less damage it wears your gun out
less quickly whereas
it wouldn't make any difference the
minimum with a 5.56 chamber could fire
223 all day long until it breaks would
not work
in in that way you don't get less wear
for less damage
but of course that's a classic rpg
trade-off
if you'd like to support what we here at
the royal armouries are doing
in various ways including over on our
own channel as well and here with our
friends at gamespot
we have links in the description for
ways that you can do that
otherwise i'll see you again next time
thanks very much
[Music]
you